today's topic oh you oh wow oh oh
wow wow so you don't so it's okay i just
want to be clear with you
it's okay it's okay for a man to go into
the women's section
show his around the other women young
little girls
under age your spa we spa
condone that is that what you're saying
i'm i'm up here at the
at the wii spa and a man okay
comes in slinging his
i i almost want to fall out i couldn't
believe what i saw
and you got some women scared to say
something
baby i'm not scared to say a thing the
blood of jesus against this
walling out lying spirit no no no
you best believe i'm gonna say something
but if they identify
he's a man i don't care so men can just
say i'm a woman today and i want to come
in
what about women's rights
[Music]
if you feel uncomfortable because we
cannot discriminate against
oh but then why do you have men's
section of women's section
gender identity if they identify us you
know they let us know so i'm a man and i
can walk in there
no don't you identify yourself as male 1
so i can tell you so we can lie
and there's a nine-year-old and a 14
year old that's never seen a penis
before
that traumatized me to see that we are
women yes and that traumatized
us yes no but i'm saying we're older
women we're not little girls right we're
here to protect the little girls
because it's not it's not okay it's not
now i can't even go
and put my clothes on because he's down
there yeah you know the whole topic of
trans people in bathrooms is one i
avoided for a long time
because i'm like how serious of a thing
this is is this really an issue
i really want to concern myself with it
right
and also truth is i'm not that affected
to be honest with you you want to say
i'm a trans man and walk into a
men's bathroom with a vagina okay
but i think it's a different story for
ladies here's the truth
there's no easy solution to this because
one she told a trans woman
to go into the men's bathroom you know
blowing the way she did
there's a lot of unsafety lack of safety
there right
because they're going into you know that
bathroom they may get discriminated
against
then they go to the women's bathroom to
perceive the certain type boy
um so i recognize that for trans folks
not an easy thing
to have to pick nope on the flip side
now we have to talk about safety and
well-being and what it means
you know let's take it from the kids
angle i can absolutely see that there
are people out there
who would take advantage of these new
laws and walk into a bathroom for kids
and hate girls and be extra creepy if we
live in a world where so much
trafficking
with so many uh dudes who like to fondle
kids with so many people who like to
of course i'm not saying trans people
out there trying to do this weird stuff
i'm saying there's people who are posing
who would if they're willing to pick
kids off the street and off playgrounds
why wouldn't they try weird stuff like
this people who flash kids
so why wouldn't they do something brazen
like that especially
if it's legal oh absolutely it's simple
for them to go in absolutely bro if i go
to the men's bathroom when there's
creepy dudes in there
yup they could be creepy in the women's
bathroom i'm sure they would do it
absolutely especially if it was legal
yeah
what you gonna tell me it's the law the
law
the law
glad you caught that throwback go back
through it
all right so so to me there's a certain
level of like
of course it's a safety issue now does
that mean we have to stigmatize trans
folks and then start
i wouldn't go that far i don't think
that's the same no but i think we also
have to acknowledge that there's no easy
solution to this me person
make a unisex bathroom men and women and
then there's a unisex
but the thing is that that this is not
just a bathroom this is where they
change
that's where the issue is amazing i
understand
i understand the issue is really the
issue is really
the fact that they have to change so
you'd have to put you know what i'm
sorry
sorry i got a daughter you got dick and
balls
yeah i'm not going to the same bathroom
yeah i'm not going the same change room
that's me other people might be so open
and liberal that they want to take
that's okay you got dick in balls you're
not going in the daughter's bathroom
is that weird listen is that weird i'm
saying no yeah
okay i'm weird but i'm saying what what
i'm saying is that as a father
my little girl wants to pee she come in
in the man's room with me
i'm not gonna let her go in the bathroom
because i've seen i've seen creepy woman
as well i'm not gonna go in the women
bathroom and whatever whatnot she's
coming with
me so if i rid of some [ __ ] that happens
i'm there how old
old 15 that's right no no no
no get out get out the door get out just
kidding
okay i'm just joking you said oh that's
like
21. oh no
you uh uh you're not going to know
women's background i'm just saying but
you got a man with his talk about he's a
woman he ain't no woman
yeah give her her money back are you
talking she's talking like she's a
manager now
yeah give her a money bag yeah just
joining back
there's no such thing as transgender he
hasn't
okay he has a he has hanging out
okay no i'm not one actually i'm a woman
who knows how to stand up and speak up
for my right
as a woman i have a right to feel
comfortable
without a man exposing himself okay
i want you to keep the fact that there's
multiple women telling this man they
felt unsafe
with a male in the women's bathroom
they felt unsafe and the man's like way
stranger you guys are being dicks
imagine a man who has no stakes in this
telling them they have no reason to feel
unsafe
after they were flashed on purpose think
about how crazy that is
you think what i'm saying yeah i can't
offend them being that's that's the
thing that's why it's really hard
because
pause so let me get this straight
that's why that's why it's a difficult
situation because
at the same time you don't want to
discriminate against a woman but you
don't want to
discriminate against trans people you
don't want
to put them in a danger dangerous spot
where they have to change
in a man's bed bathroom where it's not
only discriminated against
they can be physically harmed and you
don't want to discriminate against the
woman and the kids
that's why i'm saying it's like a
third bathroom but but again third
change room
problem solved is it gonna cost more yes
yeah
do that that's my that's my solution
yeah that's my solution
it's not a perfect solution but i mean
it is what it is that's not okay
okay that's traumatizing to see that i'm
a woman
i think this is a place right here i'm
told only for women
so how dare you sit up here and tell me
i don't have a right as a woman
i'm telling you he has a full and
testicle
okay
he was trying to do they identify he has
no i
have you i'm telling you he had a penis
veins bow six inches minimum
subway flaccid half a sub boom
meatballs with some sauce like literally
meatballs
i don't care what it's called it's a man
you got one you're a man
okay and if we went into the men's
section
with our anatomy
[Music]
i mean i mean if you wanna stay
like that i mean we could just
mean you won't go in tell me
we could just yeah that's right
but no this is that's how he came at it
yeah that's what he really but the thing
is you have to understand it's not the
same
thing with like it's not the same
situation
it's not because you reverse things that
is the same thing if i'm
if if a woman's walking home in life she
got a big ass dude following
her she gonna feel unsafe he was like
well
well if a woman is following me i wonder
if you of course not [ __ ]
it's not worth it it's not the same it's
not the same i think you don't recognize
the way in which women are made to feel
unsafe
when males enter their space
that's not the same thing this let's be
real that's not
but well it would be probably but you
might not like
women so it might not okay and we don't
know
but for me and for a lot of other women
they do not feel comfortable and it's
not okay
okay so well yeah yeah you're sorry you
should be sweetie
and you're out of alignment and this is
not right i can tell you that much
all right and i know you're out of work
yeah this must be hard it must be hard
not being a real man huh
try it okay
all right i was like all right first
you're misgendering
misgendering the person and after that
your your alley is just calling out call
them out as
i understand that you're pissed and
everything and stuff i mean she's not
just pris
she had a dude flasher in a place that
was supposed to be safe i understand she
and then the people who were supposed to
keep her safe told her you
what do you mean civility goes out the
window what do you mean
and then a man who had nothing to do
with the situation came in and told her
she had no right to want to feel safe
and to be this outrageous what do you
mean abba if you want
are you saying that there are no safe
space if you
there's supposed to be one yeah you know
but i understand what she's doing there
comes a time where it's like yo
and then who are you to come here when
you have no stakes in this and tell me
you have no right
to try to fight for my son that's what
i'm saying that's what i was about to
say basically i was like
yeah you did this and then you calling
to do whatever
but you have to take in concentration
all the thing that is
at this point she's way beyond that she
doesn't care nothing that because nobody
gives a [ __ ] about her safety that's
what i was about to say but
you picked it up so so like i said i
want every woman
get all of their information
okay well i don't care what the security
is just secure
sometimes predators go down and we'll
just go through the woman's life okay
well no he's sitting in there okay well
security
no no no no no no no no he doesn't want
him oh okay he should have not
been allowed yeah exactly exactly we
know that exactly
exactly so you know this is a difficult
cause
it's it's difficult to me it's a safe
space for females
even though you may identify as a woman
that's fantastic and if you want to
offer life
for most facets that's fine but i think
there should be certain spaces
that should be reserved why because at
the end of the day women
females have a certain fear of men
including transgender women
right you guys can understand that and
there should be safe spaces for you guys
as well
so i would include a third bathroom
that's my personal opinion i think
that's the only way you make this work
i don't think there is another way other
than you know you not having the anatomy
because it just triggers something in
people that
it's very real you know for folks who
have trauma and whatnot to see somebody
to flash you you know whether intended
or not it's like
i can understand that discomfort and
that wanting to get away
and so again this is not meant to be
like yo but i got nothing like that in
me
but if women are saying they feel unsafe
in these places
they don't want their kids around these
places they don't want their daughters
you think i think that's crazy of course
not and
i'm not even one of those people who are
like protected people are crazy about
kids right now
with trafficking and every this is this
is a a given considering what kind of
space a bathroom in a change room is
where kids and women get undressed and
change
yeah it's a very vulnerable space so
i don't think the solution is to send
the males to the men's bathroom i think
it's to create a third one that's my
personal opinion
but is that financially viable not
really so
um no easy answers to this uh for this
but yeah i think that's definitely a
discussion that needs to be raised and
correct me if i'm wrong if y'all
listen to this if there's any trance
people from the trans community that is
uh listen to this i believe that a trans
man going in a trans bathroom would have
less problems than a trans woman going
in a
woman's you want to try that
yeah let me try that again because
that's a lot of training
there's a lot there's going to be less
problems with a trans man going in a
man's bathroom and less than
uh transplant i'm going to edit it it's
fine you try
i'm gonna do it again it's not necessary
it's not
because even they're like man [ __ ] trans
people you took so long to get like
nobody cares oh it's all my fault right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah transphobia so
oh
you're just going to say yeah i got i
got a dm from riley j dennis and she
feels some type of way about your
lesson
oh until i guess i'm a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and it's important to know that the law
that came into place was made to try to
include trans women
in these spaces but didn't realize that
at the same time they may be excluding
and making
females feel unsafe in these spices as a
result so sometimes these good for
inclusivity if they're not done well
end up excluding the very people these
places were originally meant for
the reason why we made a female bathroom
was because we recognized that putting
them in a male's bathroom was not only
dangerous
but made them deeply uncomfortable so
now we're saying
okay but now we have these people who
identify as that's not how this works
there has to be more stringent
requirements or else
or else you know the whole point of the
female bathroom was to make them feel
safe and you [ __ ] it up
so that's my thoughts what was the whole
point of having women's events
in olympics we don't need to do that
again we don't need to go
we don't need to do that now we're not
no all right
so these are my thoughts on this what do
you guys think
were we being trans who knows we want to
hear your thoughts but uh
we want to hear petty cakes
[Laughter]
when we need them
[Music]
why
you calm